NOVEMBER, GOOD LUCK TO
CALIFORNIA, BUT I THINK THE
PEOPLE HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS SO MUCH AND
AS WE SWITCH INTO RECOVERY MODE,
IS IT TIME TO ASK FAUCI AND BIRX
TO CONTINUE THEIR WORK BUT MAYBE
NOT DO THESE DAILY BRIEFINGS?
POLITICO IS REPORTING THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS SHIFTING ITS
COMMUNICATIONS FOCUS FROM COVID
CONTAINMENT AND MITIGATION TO
REOPENING THE COUNTRY.
WHICH INCLUDES MANAGING THE
MEDIA BOOKINGS OF GOVERNMENT
EXPERTS LIKE DEBORAH BIRX AND
ANTHONY FAUCI.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY IS OVERSEEING
THIS EFFORT.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
ARE YOU GUYS PUTTING THE DOCS IN
A BOX?
WHAT’S GOING ON I CAN IT’S LIKE
A DR. SEUSS BOOK.
WHAT’S HAPPENING?
>> NO, THAT’S NOT THE CASE, BUT
WE DO EACH AND EVERY DAY, WE ASK
OURSELVES WHAT ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR
ABOUT, WHAT IS THE NEXT
ITERATION OF THE NEWS STORIES AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AMID THIS
PANDEMIC AND LOOK TOWARDS
REOPENING THE ECONOMY AND THAT’S
WHAT GUIDES US AND SOME DAYS
THAT MEANS DR. BIRX AND
DR. FAUCI BEING OUT THERE, BUT
IS THAT MEANS KEVIN HASSETT,
STEVEN MNUCHIN, AND ECONOMIC
TEAM, SO REALLY WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR IS
WHAT GUIDES US.
>> Laura: A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
JUST ANXIOUS FOR GOOD NEWS.
THEY DON’T WANT TO HAVE BLIND
FAITH, BUT THEY WANT GOOD NEWS,
THEY WANT OPTIMISM GOING
FORWARD.
THAT’S THE AMERICAN SPIRIT,
DR. FAUCI WAS TALKING ABOUT WHAT
COULD BE COMING, HOWEVER.
WATCH.
>> IF WE ARE UNSUCCESSFUL OR
PREMATURELY TRY TO OPEN UP, IT
COULD BE MUCH MORE THAN THAT, IT
COULD BE A REBOUND TO GET US
RIGHT BACK IN THE SAME BOAT THAT
WE WERE IN A FEW WEEKS AGO.
IT’S INEVITABLE THAT WE WILL
HAVE A RETURN OF THE VIRUS OR
MAYBE IT NEVER EVEN WENT AWAY.
>> Laura: IS THAT OUR VIEW
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE SHARES,
THAT IT’S INEVITABLE THAT WE CAN
SEE INTO THE FUTURE THAT THIS
VIRUS WILL DEFINITELY COME BACK
IF, F, F, THE STATE OPENS A
LITTLE EARLIER, NOT ACCORDING TO
EXACTLY THE POINT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PUT
FORWARD THE PHASED REOPENING
GUIDELINES.
GOVERNORS ARE FOLLOWING THEM.
AND IT’S UP TO THE GOVERNORS
ULTIMATELY WHAT TO DO, BUT LOOK,
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH A LOT OF THESE PLANS THAT
HE’S SEEN.
TODAY WE HAD RON DeSANTIS
INCOME OF THE GOVERNOR AFFORDED.
A GREAT EXAMPLE OF A STATE
THAT’S JUST DOING IT RIGHT,
THAT’S REOPENING THE ECONOMY.
THIS PRESIDENT IS LEADING THE
WAY EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
HE’S MADE THE RIGHT DECISION.
AND HE’S MAKING THE RIGHT
DECISION NOW TO LOOK TOWARDS
REOPENING THE ECONOMY.
YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT OPTIMISM.
THEY WANT CONFIDENCE THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GIVING THEM.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A REALLY
COOL TRIP BY
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE TODAY TO
THE MAYO CLINIC WHERE HE WAS
LOOKING INTO ALL THIS NEW PLASMA
TECHNOLOGY THAT MIGHT BE VERY
USEFUL IN FIGHTING THIS VIRUS AS
WE GO FORWARD AND MAYBE IF IT
DOES COME BACK IN THE FALL, BUT
THE MEDIA HAD A DIFFERENT FOCUS,
CHECK IT OUT.
>> VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
RAISING CONCERN AS HE VISITED
THE FAMED MAYO CLINIC IN
ROCHESTER, MINNESOTA, AND WAS
THE ONLY PERSON SEEN NOT,
REPEAT, NOT, WEARING A MASK.
>> IS THIS MIKE PENCE FIGURING
OUT THE TRUMPETS DECIDED THAT
MASKS OFFER PEOPLE IN HIS ROLE,
FORM OF WEAKNESS?
>> THIS IS MIKE PENCE COWERING
TO A PRESIDENT WHO DOESN’T THINK
MASKS ARE FOR HIM.
>> Laura: YOUR THOUGHTS ON
MASK SHAMING?
>> IT’S RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE ALL ROUTINELY TESTED FOR
CORONAVIRUS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE MEDIA OBSESSION WITH
MIKE PENCE WEARING A MASK IS
REALLY JUST RIDICULOUS.
WHAT THEY NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON
IS TALKING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, COVERING WITH THE
PRESIDENT DOES IN THE
WHITE HOUSE EACH DAY.
THESE SMALL BUSINESS LOANS THAT
HAVE BEEN REMARKABLE, THAT HAVE
SAVED COMPANIES, ALL THE HEALTH
UPDATES WE HAVE INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON MASK PALACE IN
TRADE, PERHAPS THEY CAN FOCUS ON
DELIVERING NEWS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO BE
DOING PRESS CONFERENCES?
YOUR PREDECESSOR DIDN’T DO THE
PRESS CONFERENCES.
WILL YOU BE DOING THEM AS TIME
GOES ON, WE MOVE INTO THIS POST
COVID WORLD WE HOPE?
>> I GEICO WITH THE PRESS ALMOST
EVERY DAY.
AND LOOK, THAT’S UP TO THE
PRESIDENT, RIGHT NOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE HEARING
DIRECTLY FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND IS NO BETTER MESSENGER THAN